good morning we're now called call to
order
the uh committee conference on the house
bill
and we'll just go around and let
everyone introduce themselves and then
we'll begin
representative wallace rockingham 12
town of danville
representative john burt goffstown where
hi i'm becky whitley i represent
district 15 which is concord henniker
hopkinton and warner
harold french senator district 7.
uh sharon carson senator district 14.
representative darrell avis our
district it's rockingham county district
8 which is the town of salem
and
we'll just start by going around the
room and let everyone is
let the our colleagues in the other body
start with their position if they want
to make any comment on the senate
amendment
thank you mr chair it seems that the one
sticking issue and i believe there's
just one
omission or we took the word use out
we tried to walk a very very fine line
with this particular bill
um
we support
uh
the second amendment
and the right of an individual to
bear arms and we felt that when we were
talking about public property
no matter what the individual has the
right to bear arms on public property i
think schools are exempt because of
federal law
but there should be nothing in place to
stop you
from carrying
or bearing arms if you are on public
property
i think where
we
ran into problems concern
the use of those guns on public property
that we recognize that municipalities
have
control over public property
and in many
towns and communities around the state
they have said that
you can't use those guns on public
property and we're talking about parks
we're talking about walking trails and
other things that are open to the public
i can
tell you that there have been instances
in my community
where people have been on public
property
um using shooting their guns and in one
instance it went through the window of a
business cafeteria
just irresponsible and because of that
the town of londonderry banned the use
of
guns
on the in the musquash which is a
town-owned property
i see the tension here
between
the right to bear arms and the right to
use arms and we do tend to regulate the
use of those
arms where they can use them and where
they can't
so the senate
addressed the
uh
the use of the weapon not whether or not
you can bear the weapon
um you have every right to do that
uh
just the same
what senator carson just said i did not
see where it was necessary to have the
word use in there so i was fine with
removing it
the lawful use for protection would be
already guaranteed under law and
the recreational use
would um
if i can mr chair we felt that
new hampshire's stand your ground law
was key that if you were on public
property and you were attacked or you
came to the defense of another that new
hampshire stand your ground would cover
that individual for using
the gun at that particular time so we
felt we did not feel the need to address
representative bert do you wish to
uh yes thank you mr chairman
um
the last time i looked uh you know
shooting anybody's window out is against
the law
so i would assume that person hopefully
was prosecuted
i know the hillsborough county behind
the hillsborough county nursing home
is
public land
and there is a you know people go up
there and shoot in the woods
you hear it all the time you know i hear
you know but they're respectful
you know because i'm assuming if they
hit the nursing home you know
i'm thinking people are going to go to
jail so that we have current laws the
word use has to be put back in
i have a selectmen in goffstown that's
i think it's pretty clear what her
intention is
and that is to regulate guns in
goffstown
and if i understand the word use from
what i'm being told by several attorneys
gun groups
if removed and stayed removed could
cause or allow the town
to
regulate
gun ranges
a private shooting range on your own
private property that's what i'm being
told
even on private land
so public and private land they can ban
uh come to the schools um
i know
hanover and other towns have tried to
ban guns in their schools
new hampshire is one of the few states
that allow guns in our schools
when they tried to ban it last term
a lot of teachers called me and said
please don't allow this to happen
because they want to carry guns to
protect the children
in case of a shooting
so luckily
you know did pass the house and the
senate and they got over to the governor
and he vetoed it
i guess
the other red flag for me is that the
new hampshire municipal association
supports this
because they know
that the town will be able to regulate
the use of guns
with the word use removed out of here
so i hope we can come to an agreement
you know to put this word back in there
you know because i don't want to give my
one selectmen that is from chicago area
the opportunity to restrict anybody in
goffstown or any district or any town
city in new hampshire
that may follow
the use of firearms on their private
property or in public properties
that
is allowed currently
now i understand that you know the
mosquits you know is an issue
i think there's other ways to deal with
that um
you know so i hope that we can come to
an agreement and put that word use thank
you
senator carson thank you um thank you mr
chairman
i think
what we did specifically was look at
public we did not look at
private property and i think um and i
can't really speak for the rest of the
uh the senate we'll have to discuss it
that we would be open to
making whatever exemptions we needed for
private property i think is entirely
appropriate because after we passed this
we heard that oh my goodness they're
going to regulate private property
especially gun ranges and we don't want
to do that to happen but the ultimate
question is
who governs the property that's owned by
the public
is it the public and they're elected
officials at the local level or is it
going to be the state
um there are there is an existing
statute and i don't recall off the top
of my head what it is
that the legislature years ago gave the
municipalities the right to regulate
their their own land their public
property within their within their
confines and so
are are we going to overrule
the um the vote of the people if they
decide we do not want people firing guns
on our public property or our is the
legislature going to say you can't do
that
um and and i think that is where things
get
really really sticky and and i
understand representative
your concern about having someone who is
comes from a place that is anti-gun i
think we all know that chicago the city
of chicago has adopted a number of
anti-second amendment laws
that just don't work i mean i think
chicago has one of the highest death
rates by
firearm in the nation and it doesn't
work but it's their law
that's what they decided to do here in
the town of goffstown
or whoever
this person is representing as a
selectman can easily be voted out
at the next election
but
i think where we're talking about public
property
um
we have to be very very careful because
everyone is the public and you have to
take into account
what the public wants in that particular
community and should the state have the
ability to override
a municipality and i think that's why
the
uh municipal association supports this
because they feel people in the
municipality should be able to govern
the property that they that they are
that they own
rather than the state
so i thought what we did was we
recognized an individual's right
constitutional right to bear arms
no one should take that away from them
unless unless there are specific
circumstances but they should be able to
take
their gun if they decide to go on
a nature walk or on a rail trail or a
walk through
any kind of property that's open to the
public
no one should tell them you cannot bring
that gun on private property absolutely
not it's the we're talking about
when is it a pro when can you use it
on public property a lot of these rail
trails and sometimes these different
parks there are people that are all
around them people that live in their
homes
and people that go out there and they
shoot
these folks don't don't want them there
they don't want them shooting
in the woods behind their house i back
to conservation land in londonderry
there are people out there all the time
shooting
doesn't bother me
i have two dogs in the fall i put orange
vests on them they're in my backyard
which is all chain linked but there's a
chance that something could happen i
take that precaution to protect
my animals
what happens behind there it's open for
hunting
have fun
you can do that and that's that was a
decision that was made and that and
that's okay but there are other places
where there there are no fences and
people just go back out there and uh
quite often representative people are
irresponsible we have a number of people
that decide they want to come up from
massachusetts
and come shooting in londonderry on our
public property and the town has
addressed that and they've closed the
musquash for shooting because of
irresponsible people
[Music]
but the question is do we take that
right away from the municipalities
and i don't have an easy answer for that
i do think though that
with this bill i it was a little
contentious because we went ahead and we
said hey listen you can
you can carry your your weapon on at
college that we got a lot of pushback
from that
but i think it's appropriate
i don't see why a college should ban
a student from having a gun if they are
a legal if they are a legal gun owner
they have every right to have that
unless they've done something wrong and
there are laws in place to take care of
that
um you know we heard stories about well
all the frat parties and people have
guns and you know people are doing it's
like no no no no no most most gun owners
are extremely responsible and they're
taught to be responsible
but
i think if we can address the private
land issue
and assure people that if you are on
your own property
you're on your own property and protect
the gun ranges i definitely think we
need to do that
with in this piece of legislation i
senator carson i couldn't ask
in respect to what happened with the
windogan getting shot out in londonderry
how close was that to where
to the person firing the firearm the
structure um they were
something that really shouldn't have
been they shouldn't have been using um
and they were caught uh our police did
uh catch them
so
but in respect to where the shot was
fired to where the building was like how
close were they um
approximately oh i i can't answer that
question i they were not adjacent to the
building
they were um
just being just completely irresponsible
they were they were in the woods and
they were firing at things and
they just
i don't know miscalculated whatever
um and it's the there is if you were to
because this is up near the airport
which is another issue
um
the manchester regional airport people
are using their weapons in the property
around the airport
um just not not a good thing because the
musk wash is
uh has parts of it that are around the
airport but if they were
caught by the police were they arrested
yes
and prosecuted
so it was
is there an existing law though that if
they're violating an existing law
if you're allowed to use a firearm on
public property you still got to respect
the other laws in the book books if you
are acting in any type of reckless
manner
you're still going to get arrested even
if you're
say allowed to use it you can't endanger
somebody if you're at a shooting range
and you
engage in reckless conduct while firing
using a firearm you're going to get
arrested so i guess by taking use out
because under my understanding current
law use is in
current law so if this were to not make
it out of this conference today the
problem
with the word use
is not solved it's still going to be an
existing law so
perhaps that issue can be solved on a
in another year because and i look at
this policy is we have a preemption law
that really doesn't have an
enforceability side of it the purpose of
this was to have a way to enforce our
state's preemption laws i think that
the intent of what this does does a good
it's allowing you to enforce it and it
puts a it puts a procedure in place for
that but all i'm saying is
we don't come to an agreement here today
the use problem is still going to be a
problem
and the lack of teachers mr chair i
would agree with you completely because
of conflicting statutes and that's what
we saw was the conflicting statute that
gives the municipality the right to
regulate
land under their control
versus here
that conflict already exists and what we
tried to do was
address that particular conflict that's
in place and say look
if you're going to if the municipality
is going to regulate
you have the right to do so but you
cannot tell someone they cannot bring
their weapon
into
on or onto private property you do have
the right
to say you can't use it here which is
which they do already in statute as well
and that is quite frankly what i think
needs to happen
is the legislature needs to look put
those statutes side by side and address
them and reconcile them
and that has not happened
but would it wouldn't the
the one that was
the most recent rsa supersede the prior
one might correct my incorrect when i
say that so there is a conflict
anyone have anything my understanding is
it would supersede the prior one
this one yeah
yes by the same we would be now removing
use and therefore every community could
regulate use out there they're going
forward and the problem with that is
it's when in rome i have a question if i
could and this may i apologize i somehow
was assigned to two committees at once
and i've yet been able to clone myself
um
have have we discussed what use means
have we discussed
in other words if we go
i'm allowed to carry my firearm
according to what the senator just said
i'm allowed to go hunting or what but if
i squeeze the trigger for whatever
reason have i violated their law
it was somewhat disgust my understanding
was that if for self-defense purposes
it's believed that you're not violating
the law
uh i think
the state i know the municipalities are
preempted
from regularly hunting as well
that's my understanding i'm worried
we're going to set up a confusing
it it exactly that's why i would think
the having a standalone
debate on use as opposed to letting this
fall
apart i think having a public hearing on
the word use and all that that would be
the way to go
because i i think at the same time
you have communities that are clearly
passing local ordinances that violate
the state law and
yeah you can go file an injunction but
and that's
i think your typical layperson doesn't
know how to do that
it's not the easiest process and it's
expensive to hire an attorney this this
gives you 307 once you get your legal
fees recovered so mr chairman what i'm
concerned about is if a municipality
by vote
a vote of the people
decide we
we don't want them to shoot on this
particular property
are we saying that you can't do that
are we telling people you don't have the
right to vote
on that particular issue well i'm
telling you the current law
already prevents that but there are
there's another rsa that
this applies to use in if it's within
300 feet
of a building and also says applies to
parks
outdoor public places for outdoor public
gatherings and playgrounds so we're not
saying all public property there's
already rsas that allow
that prohibit the use of a firearm at a
park
or a playground
so there are some restrictions already
now i think the the property you're
discussing in londonderry i'm not
certain that would fall under any of
these i'm referring to rsa
644 colon 13.
i'm just i'm not clear that that would
fall under any of those but
we're talking about a specific type of
public property
so i i just want to make sure i
understand this if i'm a private
property owner
and i do not wish to open my property to
hunting i have to go out and i have to
post it and i have to say no hunting
but the municipality on the property
that they own
they can't do that
under under existing law today that's
correct
but that's existing law so i'm saying by
walking away from this and if anyone if
i'm saying something that's entirely
accurate please correct me i'm really
going off a lot of memory up here
representative walls thank you mr
chairman just a simple
question from my members from the other
body what about the simple modifier
putting that back in
okay
i think you know we can consider that
lawful use is just that all lawful
purposes
so if somebody was being negligent as
you described in the already adjudicated
situation in your hometown of
londonderry wouldn't that would this
this bill would allow prosecution to go
forward because it would not be a lawful
use of the firearm would you agree
senator i i could agree with that
representative rory thank you mr
chairman um just to the to the group in
general i think i understand what
senator carson is saying about you know
localities getting together and a
community of 300 people all vote no
we don't want any guns but what if that
same community people got together and
said
you need a permit for speech
i mean the second amendment is
is a fundamental right of the citizens
so no locality municipality know how no
matter how well intentioned
is allowed to take away fundamental
rights just because
the mob if you will decided they don't
want it it's a fundamental american
right so no other we would not tolerate
it with any other
constitutional right
for our municipality to say you can't do
this here
although regulating it is is legitimate
but we have to be very careful because
it is a fundamental right
representative nice senator whitney
sorry thank you mr chair so just to that
point i you know
every right that we have another
constitution is important every right
and not one right should be elevated
over another and so the what you're
descri exactly what you're describing
would surely be challenged and not be
constitutional this you know
permit for for
right exactly
so
every
if if a government decides to act
right then it needs to be
they have to have a governmental
interest and it needs to be balanced
right exactly so but but
i think it gets lost in the second
amendment conversation it is a right
under the constitution and people
interpret it different ways but it
should not be elevated over every other
right and so i think what senator carson
is describing is you know individuals
have property rights and in new
hampshire we care deeply about property
rights and i think we're also talking
about you know
town owned property is the property of
the entire municipality and there are
property rights there that need to be
balanced against the second amendment
and let me know if i'm speaking
incorrectly but all the point i'm trying
to make is
a separate standalone bill can be filed
to address use under rsa
644 colon 13. i'm just saying the issue
of use
is one topic this has to do with
enforcing having some way to enforce the
preemption laws for the communities that
completely ignore the state law if we're
going to have any type of preemption
whatsoever there needs to be a procedure
to enforce it and to not be something
that's going to be a tremendous
financial burden as someone you have a
legal background i'm sure you know that
legal expenses can really pile up for
someone
who's trying to simply address this this
gives them that and then why don't we
have the use conversation on a separate
bill so just to respond to that and by
the way i was a public interest lawyer
so i was never making the big bucks a
little lawyer but to respond to the
folks you interacted with there were two
but to respond to that you know if
that's the case then let's just strip
the law i mean i'm not saying that this
is something i would support but if
that's the case then just strip the rest
um because representative roy came in
late
what we did was
we recognized the right that no
municipality has the right to tell any
gun owner they
do not have the right to take that gun
onto any
public property except i mean schools we
know public schools are different
but
whatever public property they own
the no municipality can tell
me senator french you anybody else who
owns a gun and carries gun that you
cannot take that on to public property i
think that was something that we felt
very very strongly but
our concern was the use and it is that
tension between gun owners
and people that own the property
and the municipalities own that property
and do they have the right to regulate
the use of that weapon on public
property that's that is the ultimate
question here and there are conflicting
statutes
one statute says they do
but then you've got gun laws over here
that conflict and that's what we're
dealing with is this conflict but i i
hope we can all agree
that no municipality has the right to
tell a lawful gun owner that they do not
have the right to take that weapon onto
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman and i agree with you and i
think that the the lawful use
of a firearm would also
uh cover any concerns that some of us
have about
um
the general use policy so for example um
it would allow and provide for the
protections on private property as well
because
lawful use would be all permitted
purposes on private property you know
and adding that lawful use it keeps
everything on the up and up and removes
uh
representative
silver's here you are the prime
sponsor of hb307
you heard a comment by representative
wallace
about perhaps
putting the word use back in but it's
saying lawful use
do you have any comment on that any
thank you mr chairman
the existing preemption law contains the
worst word use
the amend the senate amendment would
take that out reenact the pre the
preemption law adding some enforcement
mechanism but take the word use out
so
there is the the statute the other rsa
dealing with unlawful use of firearms in
different parts of a municipality
already exists
so what the senate amendment does it
takes the word use out
i don't see that there's any reason to
change the existing
language of the preemption law all we're
i haven't considered that i think
you
as it as the preemption law exists with
the word use in there
there is a
implied requirement in law that
everything you're permitted to do in law
must be lawful so it's already there
it's it's implied in law everything is
has to be done lawfully if you don't if
it's not done lawfully there's an rsa
that already governs itself respectfully
we spend a lot of time and effort
cleaning up ambiguities in a law on a
regular very regular basis around here
would you agree
yeah
mr chair is to understand the point the
unlawful use
we don't need to
by saying lawful use we're basically
saying the unlawful use is illegal which
is already illegal
which is quite well taken represented
um mr chair if i if i might um if we
could take a recess
um so the senate can caucus
you may take all
a short
research
huh
i call a
committee of conference meeting on house
bill
to order
and uh
i guess my opening statement would be i
i was curious as to why the repeal
and we discussed it and i understand
what the reasoning was
but by repealing that section we take
out
the restitution
part of it
so i'm wondering if we can come to an
agreement
where on uh
roman numeral four
we can only just we just take out shall
be guilty of a violation
and leave the restitution in we wouldn't
have to renumber anything it's just a
simple change
but the reason for the house bill 1011
was when people vandalized property we
had vandalism at the state house
we know who the vandals were but we they
wouldn't pay
all wasn't a violation it was don't they
didn't have to pay
in their mind
you got to have a a hammer hanging over
their head that was the reason for the
bill and
by deleting that section
so i i think if we can
it was changed the staff itself changed
um and we went back again we went back
and looked and we went back to the stats
what it was the way it was prior to the
change oh
i'm sorry i keep forgetting about these
it's gonna i think
this whole thing
is is going to take a little while to uh
to get used to what we did mr chair was
we just went back to the statute
um as it was had been prior to two i
think it was either 2019 or 2020 when it
had been changed the penalty had been
lowered and we wanted to make sure that
the higher penalty was in place because
i think at the time that it was changed
um there were a lot of
issues with public property being
defaced and that was statues and things
that were being torn down
and uh the penalties were lowered and we
we did not want that in place we wanted
the higher uh penalty to be in place um
but if you are just looking to um
uh have the restitution piece i don't
think that i i can't speak for my
committee members right now but i mean i
think it's we can definitely consider
that if that's the only thing you really
i'm learning
that was the reason for the bill terry
path came to me uh
oh in a previous session and we tried
and we didn't get it because of covert
so we we tried it again and uh
obviously we didn't look into it as
carefully as you did
but the restitution piece was important
because they when they vandalized out
front of the state house
they caught the vandals
yes
and even
bringing it back to the misdemeanor with
a stiffer penalty it doesn't provide for
restitution it provides for a fine which
may or may not cover and it doesn't
direct where the fine goes generally
fines go to the general fund which
doesn't do the restitution so that's why
we wanted the restitution okay so are
you saying um it's an either or that
they pay a fine
or a restitution or pay a fine and a
restitution
i would say it should be uh either or um
up to the judge i don't know what you
guys think
well
the restitution is to the is to the
whoever's property has been damaged
as a result of the vandalism the fine is
something that's just paid
kind of as a penalty for the offense
right but i don't want to make it so
that it's impossible to pay and then
nobody gets anything and they just end
up in jail i'd rather see the money get
to where it belongs so if it's
um i'm either way i'm okay i just
i don't want to do double
as written you can't draft the rsa to
say this but my understanding in the
in the world when this is in a court
when when people work out a deal
sometimes providing restitution to the
property is something that's
considered favorable towards although
the the county attorney is not going to
help negotiate a private
civil settlement but they're gonna
basically if you pay restitution or are
willing to
that's something that luigi's
sometimes considered well let me ask is
do you feel that it's more important to
i think we're talking about public
property here and if they don't pay the
taxpayers pay
that's my my feeling
and if they damage something that's uh
well of historical value or or something
that's up to the judge
every case is different do you think
that if someone destroys something of
historical value and they're fined
fifty dollars
that doesn't get it it doesn't cut it
and i i was thinking that you've got
many communities in new hampshire you
have your town
center
and you know you have your statues of
your civil war veterans and and you know
you can have uh i know in londonderry we
have
um they sold bricks with names of of
people in honor of and it's all part of
this town common area
and they go out and seed it and you've
got the grass is growing nicely and
somebody decided they wanted to go four
wheel on it and ripped up all the lawn
fifty dollars
uh fine
is not gonna
compensate
for the damage that's been done so
that's why i asked what do you think
would be more appropriate because i
agree
i don't think it would be appropriate a
fine and restitution is it more
important to pay restitution than a fine
my basic feeling is if there's a jail
sentence involved
if i were the judge i'd impose the jail
sentence
suspended
provided the guy makes restitution and
that's the the
carrot and stick that uh we were looking
for
yeah restitution yeah
an either or somehow in other words
because somehow there might be something
where restitution is not appropriate i'm
trying to think of a situation where
there wouldn't be
necessary restitution
but i can't think of one so maybe we
just do restitution
well
if i may mr chairman if you have someone
who has
um
destroyed a historical document
it's you can never be replaced it's it's
now gone
what and it would be up to the court to
determine
what is the restitution
um
so
i agree with that and i'm not the judge
i think uh
in cases whether we give the tools to
the judge let the judge make the
decision
okay can we can we take um maybe 10
minutes mr chair for the senate to
caucus and
we can um and we will be right back sure
i'm not the chair oh i'm sorry i'm
we'll be in recess until you come back
okay thank you
i will reconvene the committee now and
uh
mr chairman we'd like to offer this as a
as an amendment
um that i think
that's good
okay
i think so
yeah that's um
okay
yeah
we had you had violation in the brackets
okay
yeah
okay so i think we are in agreement on
the language so
i believe the procedure is we will aced
from our position you will aced from
your position and we will adopt this as
the new position
and we will
uh
then
who's going to make up the amendment
i'll take care of that
that's what i was afraid of
oh it's a house bill's representative
that's why we brought representative
abbas in
to uh you know
make sure we're getting the language
correctly from two attorneys and i'm
sure representative rabbits will be more
than happy to help you get this done
well that sounded good we still mess it
up
right now
see
you can have all the attorneys in the
room that you want and there's still
mistakes being made so well if you have
five attorneys you got at least six
opinions
huh she's a she's a fellow senator i'm
not going to criticize her so
okay so i think we're
i'll see you on friday
yes
friday
yes i know
i know i had to stop and think about
what was going on on friday so okay all
right um i'd like to thank mr layman for
helping us with making sure we get this
language
as well correct thank you very much
thank you so we will now
close the
not available
well now when i'll call the order the
committee conference on house bill
just quickly let everyone introduce
representative wallace rockingham 12
danville
representative rhodes cheshire 15
winchester richmond marlborough swansea
troy
representative roy rockingham 32 candy
uh becky whitley i represent senate
district 15.
herald french
uh senate district seven
and uh sharon carson sharon carson um
senate district 14.
representative darryl lavis i represent
rockingham county district 8 which is
just before we begin the
the two verge the senate version in the
house version there com there's no
conflicting language amongst the two
and
the cena version there was a supreme
court case that came down
there was some conflicting language
between some of the regulations and some
of the rsas
my understanding is that the senate
amendment what it would do it would
address that inconsistency which i think
is a good thing because that should be
solved
right away however
the underlying bill has been completely
removed i am the prime sponsor of that
bill and i thought it was a good policy
it what it did is for third and fourth
offenses
expanded the look back period from what
is now 10 years 20 years we're talking
about drunk driving convictions
we passed this
in the house criminal justice committee
last term it passed
um
it was all ultimately tabled but then at
the same time this year we passed it and
i think it went on the consent calendar
so
my understanding they thought the
20-year look-back period from
repeat offenders was too long of a time
period
so i guess the question is what we want
to do about it if anyone has any comment
send whitley thank you mr chair
so on the look back issue you know we
have to balance this with what we're
trying to accomplish and if we're trying
to accomplish getting folks to not
reoffend again
putting them in jail is not the not the
right way to do it if people are
offending this many times it's because
they're they have a disease they have
you know they are alcoholics likely and
and to and to get them to not reoffend
again is to get them into treatment
maybe it'll take the third a third time
maybe they'll take a fourth time we know
that the way that this disease
progresses that people need to attempt
treatment many times putting them in
jail is not gonna you know help them get
better and so i think the senate uh
thought that that look back was a little
bit too long and thought that the
existing law we didn't hear many
problems with it it's the it's a good
policy because you know it
punishes people when necessary but also
um you know allows people to continue to
get treatment when necessary which is
the most effective way to get them to
yeah i had a problem with uh
21 years old get two dwis
back to back and then
the third one comes at 41 years old and
we're holding him to this long look back
so i was against the 20-year
can i just say ditto
i mean we we did have great discussions
i think
about this particular issue i think
senator whitley makes
a great point about her reason why
20 years might be
excessive as well as senator french
20 years is a long time and a person can
change within 20 years and you could
have an 18 year old or 20 year old go
through a period of their life where
they might be drinking a little bit too
much and they
they get a dui
and it's going to follow them around for
the next 20 years and if they should
uh offend for a third time there's some
extremely stiff penalties
so i i
um i i just felt that 20 years was just
too much of a look back wait wait too
long
i respected
you know alcoholisms that can be is a
disease but
offenders of this crime are not
necessarily alcoholics
there there's people who get
commit this offense and
we were just making the presumption that
they are
so my concern is in the way i understand
how the law would work
in order to be charged with a second
offense you would have had already been
convicted of the first offense
so if you are charged with your first
offense and get arrested again
that would be another first offense you
actually have to have the conviction
before you move on to the next
your license is going to be suspended
for a portion of that time period at the
second offense same thing
we hear about people on
you see in the news and it's all over
the country you'll come across it this
person's been arrested or convicted five
six times for drunk driving what happens
is when you have such a short look-back
period of 10 years
is the person is really getting
convicted of first and second offenses
several times over
so we're not necessarily addressing the
problem it's not about throwing someone
in jail but we have someone who
i think in a 10-year time period has an
ample opportunity to seek help for the
condition they have
and
we have a situation that's endangering
the public
i respect the opinion on that
but i guess i would be open to see what
what we're willing to compromise on
obviously the other section of this
the other this the amendment from the
from the senate is important addressing
drunk driving we if we care about
enforcing those penalties and doing it
properly
why would we not consider a
a harsher penalty for
if you're going to continue it's not a
harsher penalty but extend look back
period for repeat offender
mr chair okay
representative roy
also to your point
what we're not taking into account in
the discussion is please
so you get arrested for a dui you don't
necessarily get convicted you could
plead
so now you've got someone who's been
arrested for a numerous dua but you can
only look at the convictions and look
back period
so in that 10 years they could get
another and another and if they plead to
a lesser offense or it gets continued
without a finding
then the look-backs don't trigger so i
think that
an extension of the current look-back
period i think is definitely in order
just because of the fact that not all of
them end up in convictions
um
because they plead to something else
20 years okay as daryl said that maybe
too much is is there a number that may
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman i want to echo
what representative roy said he
actually studied before i had the
opportunity is that many times these
crimes are played down
exactly what he said i can't say it any
better and
that does not take away the fact that
yes you may have a person that does have
a disease but you also have a person
that may have lost their life because of
another person's disease
and that does not mean that the person
has not
has not had the opportunity or has not
already gone through a treatment program
many many times there are
several
several programs out there to help
people that have
mental illnesses diseases of all sorts
that does not mean that you cannot hold
a person accountable for their own
actions whenever they're putting someone
thank you mr chairman
yeah so i think you know if
i mean the set the senate made our
decision on the look back and i think it
be it would be helpful for me to see any
you know because i don't want to just
sort of speak on
uh what happened in other states or sort
of rhetoric it would be helpful if the
house had any information about this
actually being a problem in new
hampshire
uh
you know that would be helpful i think
any change to a look back we need to
yes
that is an example the problems with
that one is there was no
it was
those are all still first offenses
they're and they're all they're all
separate so you
whether there's five separate charges
from separate incident you can have a
conviction on one two three who knows so
it's hard to
that's more of an issue of bail if you
in respect to the data
i mean
i wouldn't say drunk driving is a
problem that's overwhelming the state
that we need to
duck for cover here but it's still a pr
it's still an issue that's affecting us
and all i'm saying is if you look at the
penalties for a second offense
there's two different categories you can
follow one of them if you're arrested
within i think it's within a two year
period of the first offense but assuming
you don't fall in that you're looking at
it's 12 you can have a 17-day
uh
sentence but 12 of those are suspended
so you would have
five days must be served in the house of
corrections for this second offense the
third offense
is it's 180 days but you can have 150
suspended so you're looking at
at 30 days
all right so we're talking about an
additional 25 days assuming you're first
and second we're not within a two year
time window for the fourth offense
it's also
a
it's the same 180 days 50 150 which can
be suspended so between a third and
fourth
the amount of time served
is actually in jails
it's the minimum sentence is the same
it's the second offense if the second
offense is within two years of the first
offense
that is also
well it's it's 60 days but it's a 30
days suspended so you're doing 30 days
so the only time where you have that
increase is if your second offense is
racing within
two years after the first but within
that 10-year time period that may have
third offense is a five-year loss of
license with the max of an indefinite
suspension
but
look
it
mr chairman considering a
a driving is a privilege right not a
rate that's actually a
i would have to agree with
representative hawaii that
that's that's a reasonable request
i i think the concern is that
in order for you to prosecute third and
fourth offenses is that the often the
third offense is often not going to
mr sheriff i may i don't
i don't think we're prepared
to sit here and look at rewriting the
dui statutes
i think what the issue here is the
20-year look back
i believe i heard and i think it's
representative roy say is there a
different number
that you would be willing to entertain
um
you guys want 10 i want the 20 i think
[Music]
here's the thing i just you know
i have to have a reason for us to want
to change it and like i hear
you know i i just don't see that this is
i don't hear that this is a problem in
new hampshire like if this is
i don't want to ruin lives as senator
french
is indicating i don't want to ruin lives
when we don't know that this is actually
happening
like in the house did you hear testimony
from law enforcement from whoever that
and they have the data about it i would
love to see that
so you're telling me that you want data
on whether people are arrested for drunk
driving three times
no data's supporting the need for a
20-year look-back
data supporting the need for a 20-year
look-back or data supporting the need
for a 15-year look back what i'm saying
is that we that we have a 10 year look
back now
and
that that seems to work and then like i
don't you know if there is data to
support the need to change the look back
then that's what we need to see
i'm going to be honest
i'm looking at the time period of how
this would play out unless you're you're
getting your subsequent offenses without
a valid license i'm just pointing out
that
it's unlikely
second offense is a three-year loss of
license
all right i'm just assuming that you're
complying with the law in that time
period
it's really seven years that you're
allowed to legally be driving i'm not
counting if the breathalyzer side of and
all that i mean there's more that can go
play into this
i'm just it's for a third offense we're
saying oh we don't want to
be able to charge my third offense we
need data to see that i'm just pointing
out
it's a third offense
whether the look back periods 10 years
20 years 30 years it's still the third
time they've done it so is it a problem
define what a problem is how many times
does it have to happen before it's a
problem that we address i'm telling you
is it happening to the point that this
is an emergency and we must deal with it
right away i don't think that's the case
but i don't need to see the frequency of
how long it's time often it's happening
i just see from a practical sense
your third offense or a fourth offense
all right if the person needs help
they've had plenty of time to get help
now
i understand 20 years is people want to
be critical of that i i understand that
at least where they're coming from i
thought i think 15 years would be
a reasonable compromise
that's my my humble opinion i mean
i think that just is a misunderstanding
of the way that the disease progresses
you know you can't put a time frame i
mean that that's a whole separate issue
giving them enough time to get into
treatment you know if if the goal is to
get these people to not do these bad
things anymore we want them we want to
give them the time to do the treatment
don't we
you're assuming that the offenders are
an alcoholic again correct and but and
also the you know
changing the well i mean if someone is
reoffending three or four times
but there's a pretty high likelihood i
mean that's what we hear from the
treatment folks too also it doesn't
address this issue that senator french
is talking about about the age
difference and how you know we
mature right so if you have you know we
know and senator carson mentions this a
lot too that brains aren't fully
developed until 25.
okay so you you have
you know two offenses even at 25.
right and then you have your third event
offense so you know it's complicated and
i think like you know of course we want
to be
we're not saying that it's not a problem
that they are having third offenses
that's not what we're saying
correct what we're saying is that if
we're going to change the the look back
we need to understand the significance
of how how much this is happening i'm
having a hard time falling you so a 21
year old their brain's not developed
enough to the point they understand that
drinking and driving creates a public
safety risk
i it's all different i i don't i have a
hard time we allow them to drink at age
legally if they're not mature enough to
drink i mean
but
they're not going to give them a the
same punishment for drunk driving now
well and we're also talking about the
ability to get into treatment too right
mr chairman
my understanding is a lot of times
when a person is
is in front of a judge for drinking and
driving whether it's a plea or
the actual conviction a lot of times
treatment is part of the sentence
a lot of i think
i've never known it not to be part of
the sentence the fact of the matter is
i i i think i'm having a hard time
understanding how we can sit here and
say
well
because a person has this
this problem
we're going to justify
not looking back because they may have
had a problem
i mean it's a problem when
a person's coming home from work when
they're 18 years old and they get hit by
a drunk driver that's they've
done it three or four times that's
that's a serious problem and they're
still going to be and so i think we need
to be clear they're still going to be
punished we're not saying that these
people should not be punished
right that they that
the punishment is still there we're just
talking about the look back
right
it would be for first
punishment would be for would be for a
first offense though that's the problem
we're saying is that you're right they'd
still be punished but as a first-time
offender even though they had been
convicted twice times two times before
um
is there any other crime that we can
think of that has a look-back period for
this is the only one we give we give
this kind of a treatment to where
well it's not your subsequent offense if
so much time is passed uh every other
offense is
mr chair it's it's my understanding and
i'm looking back at the testimony
we heard in the senate
that
the 20-year look back is for third and
fourth offenses only
so
i i mean when we did this quite frankly
we were really concentrating on the
definition of the word way
because there had been a recent supreme
court decision on rudder versus dmv that
affected how
uh way was determined and we the
attorney general came in and and they
were like we really need this defined
um
i think that um senator well
we will consider an alternate um is
there a proposal for
something other than 20 years i i would
propose 15 years
okay so 15 years as a compromise i think
senator french and i can accept that i
don't believe senator whitley can we'll
replace her and we can see how he does
that
we can um
so my my suggestion mr chair is to
uh prepare that as a compromise
um and
so just to clarify that the house
version as written except for making it
a 15-year lookout well we need um well
we need the definition of way yes and
this is a compromise you will accept the
definition of way we will accept 15
years and that's the compromise we will
accept the senate
section word for word
house version make it 15 as opposed to
20. yes
so everybody's okay with the definition
of way
and why must that be part of this bill
it it needed to be it was that supreme
court case i don't know it was march or
whenever it came down
right now
with the conflicting definitions of what
a way is that's an element of proving
the offense
i
i do credit the mighty fine defense work
that was done to to catch that however
that does need to be addressed right
away
like
that's
this was this bill it was least
at least according to our friends in
the senate it would believe to be
germane to the topic
okay
the attorney general did contact me
before that hearing
asking my thought you know sent me the
case i reviewed it i had no problem with
it being ad i gave it my blessing to add
it i was hoping my
underlying bill would survive as well
and apparently did not
but i was all right with what the
attorney general was going for
and i think it does address an immediate
problem it does mention some privately
held lands that's my concern
so private land can be like but keep in
mind you go to like a grocery store
that's it's commercial property but it's
private but public has a right of access
that's different
[Music]
section b beginning on line 28 on page
one
it says it says any person convicted of
a violation of rsa 265
a colon two section i subsection a and
the and the conviction is based you know
blah blah blah
or under reasonable equivalent offense
in an out-of-state jurisdiction
occurring within
10 years of the date of the present
offense
so
um
shall be guilty of a class a misdemeanor
do we want to make that consistent
between
i think the intent of what that section
was is that if you did get a subsequent
offense
what it was doing
a
conviction for a first offense is a
class b misdemeanor this was this is
making it a class
a
i just wanted to know what they were
doing yeah
so
so if you're going to use 15 that
section
b
15 as well
we catch
we have no
that we'll we're okay with that okay
thank you whoever
yeah
we so we are in agreement we're in
agreement okay so we look forward to
seeing the report
thank you very much mr chair
and we are done
we now close the committee conference on
just
before we before we break any longer
my friends in the senate in respect to
hb three or so i'm just going to reopen
that and state the time that we're gonna
that's when you said you were available
so if you can do it earlier that would
i don't think i said that on
so we would now just i have to quickly
open it and say it
we're now reopen the committee
conference on house bill
and we're going to be on break
until
everyone will be in the same room at
least
yes
good afternoon we're now called to order
the
committee conference on house bill 1476
before we begin we just go around let
everyone introduce themselves for the
record
i'm representative ross berry represents
south manchester in the town of
litchfield
representative jennifer rhodes cheshire
district 15 winchester richmond richmond
marble swansea troy
representative terry roy rockingham 32 i
represent candy at deerfield northward
soucy senate district 18 manchester's
wards five through nine in the town of
litchfield
senator bill gannon from sandown the
heart of the wine country of new
hampshire
good afternoon representative daryl
abbess representing rockingham county
just before we have two
two versions of this there is a
pass in the senate and one there's a
version of passing the house that
they're very different
they could technically on their own
survive
together
but they don't necessarily have to
they address different parts but if you
want to go around let each side
explain their position on each one we
representative barry
so
1476 is passed by the house is
significantly different than what the
senate excuse me replaced it with
1476 addresses repeat
arrestees more than likely criminal
offenders but you are innocent until
proven guilty so we're talking 1476
deals with people who are currently out
on bail and are arrested again
for
if you have an area that has been
affected by the bail reform city of
manchester rochester
you know anywhere you find one of the
county jails
you get a lot of the
negative effects of
the rapid release of people who are
arrested committing crimes
because they're dumped back out into
your community um so somebody who's
who's arrested in medford or new boston
ends up in my city of manchester um
often to be
rapidly arrested again and if you listen
to the patrolmen
whose i've spoken with extensively
they will arrest people who are laughing
in the back
of their squad car because they know
that they will be back out onto the
streets before the officer has finished
the paperwork
so 1476 attempts to address that and
close that so that people can stop
flouting the law
specifically in manchester in our other
cities such as nashua rochester i
imagine conker probably experiences some
of this as well
so that is what 1476 deals with it's on
the second arrest for all crimes
and then it's on the third arrest for
class b misdemeanors that was
that was done as a negotiation
with people who were opposed to it
because getting a coalition together
to to pass the house has been a um
well if you think i worked hard on
redistricting i promise you i worked
harder on bail reform in the house it
takes a
lot of negotiation a lot of explaining
things
and 1476 when it passed the house passed
representative rory
thank you uh i just wanted to um follow
up a little bit on what representative
connolly said
it's it's um
barry excuse me sorry
it's um
it's not just certain towns that are it
affects every single town in new
hampshire
there's no borders and
um
even the smaller towns that have to deal
with this issue be it people they had to
release or people released from other
communities so i it affects the entire
state
representative
i spoke with a
chief
from up north who told me that
he had um
arrested the same individual three or
four times
and that individual ended up oding and
dying
and he said you know we could have done
something for that person but we just
kept taking him in and throwing them
back out taking him in and throwing him
back out taking him in and throwing it
back out
um
you know this is this is a real
i think when and i wasn't here when the
legislator
passed the last bail reform package but
i did watch and go through and read all
the notes and i don't think that was
anybody's intention i think the original
bail reform was supposed to be targeted
towards making sure that people weren't
holding poor people for minor crimes um
i think that's something we can all
agree on but when we we're we're talking
about people who are already out of bail
i mean these are people who've been
senator bradley uh good afternoon mr
chair so um
as you know we've worked together on
this language
the language
that the senate adopted in
house bill 1476
is your language representative abbas
you gave it to us
we adopted it
as is
we obviously consulted with
the police chiefs
we dropped the provision in
house bill or senate bill 294 that was
similar to the provision in
representative berry's bill
at
your
suggestion because you thought it would
be
easier to get it through the house so
i've done
and the senate has done
the difference between the two bills
is that
the language in the senate version of
1476 actually
targets the biggest problem the violent
offenders i would like to have repeat
offenders in
and if it's the will of this committee
of conference
we could
either
make sure that the language of
representative barry's bill is
consistent with
um you know the provisions that you
wrote in 1476 or we could go to the
language in 294
that talks about repeat offenders i'm
happy to do that but it was your
suggestion representative abbas that we
dropped it
so i'm good with that because it was
your suggestion
but it targets violent
the language in the senate bill targets
violent
criminals and that's where the biggest
problem is and that's what we should be
focused on
respectfully when it comes to drop in a
section
and with senate bill 294
which
that section if that bill has drafted or
even some of the amendments that float
on floated around the house would
conflict because it's a much longer more
intensive bill would have a provision
that would conflict
with what
hp
uh
1476 does
so in what i sent it it doesn't change
this section the reason why is that they
conflict so you can have a debate on
just 1476 and then the rest of what 294
would have done
senate bill 295 the idea is to not have
you don't want to have
a
much larger bill impacting this because
if that bill wanted to go forward this
bill would not have its own
and that's why your suggestion we
dropped the repeat offender provision
and it's not in the center pass version
of 1476.
i'm i'm referencing 294. 294. i don't
want to i don't want to actually address
the idea was i'm just saying that when
we discussed 294 which we did
[Music]
quite a bit
and the language that is now in 1476 is
what you gave me visa v294
so
i went with your suggestion to drop
the repeat offenses and we just stuck
with your language on 1476.
the reason why i wouldn't change 1470
because i sent it was an amendment to
senate bill 294 exactly but the point
i'm making is we're willing to accept
your suggestion your so-called
compromise but the more important piece
of this entire effort is violent
criminals and i think that's pretty
clear and i think my conversation that
representative barry you and i had a
couple of weeks ago offline
was that
if
you know and i don't want to put words
in your mouth but certainly my memory of
the conversation was
we should be targeting
violent criminals and that's what the
cenopass version does with the support
of the police chief so we're out there
day in and day out
defending
our communities i agree repeat offenders
are a real problem but
i think the larger problem is people
that
have been alleged to have committed a
violent crime getting bail immediately
and then
recommitting another violent crime that
they should have been held for and see a
judge
before they get
bailed and to me
that should be the focus of
what we're doing especially since
representatives your language
i i i like it and i did i did help write
it but my understanding is getting it
over the finish line is the issue
and
this
past in the house i can't even get the
other my language
for a discussion on the house and i
tried very hard what can i normally
report on
this bill in the senate if i might and i
think there is you know representatives
of law enforcement maybe you'd call on
them to also talk about it but in the
hearing report on
chief ho becky
said specifically they support senate
bill 294 because it addresses the issue
of violent repeat offenders and how to
remedy many of the situations that have
occurred so
when they were talking about 1476 they
were referencing what the real problem
is violent offenders in that hearing
that's why i mean we
in the senate
took your language
and put it into representative barry's
bill because that's the bigger issue i
agree
repeat offense is a problem but i think
we should be
you know targeting
the bigger problem
and just
let's understand the two policies here
hp 1476 is passed by the house what it
does
someone's out on bail
there's a couple other
if they're on bail waiting a sentence
what not
the person is charged with a class b
misdemeanor which is a by the way it's a
crime that you wouldn't ordinarily go
jail for
third or subsequent events it shall be
detained for a period not
that's not more than 36 hours
what
the other
the senate version that i helped draft
what that would do
you don't necessarily have to be out on
bail so you can be dealing with a
first-time offender but the crimes
you're dealing with are much more
serious
violent crimes against a person
or a sex crime against a child that's
what the scope of what the list of
offenses are and in that case it's the
same thing it's 36 hours you're not
going in front of a bail commissioner
you're going in front of a judge
now the appetite of the house i'm i i
will never understand why they would
support
1476 but not what
i was hoping would be
an amendment to senate bill 294 but
that's what happened so here we are so i
guess what can we get over the finish
senator susan could i just add something
because i was actually one of the people
sitting around the table we negotiated
the original bail reform and you're
correct that the intent was to ensure
that just because somebody didn't have a
dollar in their pocket they weren't
sitting in
in jail um
flash forward and living in the city of
manchester and talking to the chiefs and
recognizing there have been some
instances where
because and we don't need to get into a
whole discussion about the bail
commission system but let's just say the
system has had difficulties i think
handling the bail reform legislation as
it currently is particularly as it
relates to extremely violent offenders
and what that has in turn done is made
some victims
unwilling to
participate in the prosecution of the
alleged perpetrator
when this bill passed when 294 passed
but particularly when the version of
1476 past the senate passed on a 21-3
vote
um there were there was one republican
two democrats that made up the three and
then obviously the balance of the senate
so the legislation
as it stands before you
the senate version has significant
bipartisan support and just to reiterate
senator bradley's concern
the concern we were hoping to address
was those who have committed violent
offenses and ensuring
that there was the ability for a judge
to make the determination
and i think that's how we got to where
we are at least from this side of the
table and i do recognize that obviously
the the house
reacted differently but it was it was
clear and it was bipartisan in our
support
representative ross
representative sorry i've been called
no one's wrong here
no one's wrong here and that's the
problem
um
the addressing the violent offense is
something that on a personal level i
would love it if we would do that and
senator bradley's not incorrect i would
wholeheartedly support that in fact i'd
probably go a step further that many
people here wouldn't be comfortable and
i get rid of pr bail entirely i think
i don't i don't like cashless bail
i've made that clear from the beginning
so it's not a it's not a lack of of will
on at least the people that are here for
the violent crimes um
the issue we have is we have to count
votes in the house
and it is something um
you know you had three two democrats and
one republican the only people that
opposed
your bill but i had i believe
um
it would be in the hundreds
when we had similar language come across
to the house
and i'm not speaking let me be very
clear i'm about i'm not speaking for
myself right now
the house
the house bought the house majority of
which i was not a part
does not like
the
one and done i disagree with them
wholeheartedly i disagree with them but
i also have to live in the reality of
counting votes
and we were able to count votes and get
1476 across
um i fully acknowledge it's a much
higher easier hurdle to get what i view
as the right thing done in the senate
but unfortunately there's just no
appetite in the house under its current
makeup we have an election in november
hopefully things will change hopefully
people will change out by the way on
both sides it's not exclusively a
partisan issue there are some partisan
lines but it is not exclusively a
partisan issue when we
when we passed 1476 i had
many manchester democrats helping me and
cheering me along the line some of them
co-sponsored this
so
what i'm saying my message is is the
votes do not exist
for anything that looks like 294 or 92.
i'm also saying i wish they did
i wish they did and i would fight like
hell to get them in fact i did
they just don't exist
the votes exist for 1476. i wish 1476
went farther i wish it had a provision
about one and done on violent crimes i
just made my position about pr bill
known entirely i want it gone entirely
but it doesn't exist
and if we continue to push a position
that will die in the house that i cannot
control
we are basically saying we are done for
the year we're not going to do anything
we're going to keep letting people out
it's never going to stop
and i know i'm not trying to impugn your
motive i understand your motive i agree
with it that you want to
stop the violent offenses i'm all in
but i have to live in reality and the
reality is is when this when something
similar like this came across
and they tabled it and i believe the
table was two to one
and then when they went to take it off
the table it died three to one
the house is a weird beast i'm a
freshman but i've learned a lot in two
years and i feel like i feel like in
certain ways i've served like four terms
in two years
but i have learned that once
that body makes up its mind and votes
one way moving it is a
nearly insurmountable task and you're
asking of us
to do something
that i i just don't know where i'm gonna
find the votes i had to do things to get
for i had to water down 1476 you go back
and you look at the speech i i even said
at one point i got criticism ironically
enough from people on the left i was
like how much more are you going to
water this down i said until we get the
votes
and i stopped when we had the votes and
it just it just is what it is and i i
don't want to leave here with nothing
but you guys need to understand that
you're effectively putting us in the all
or nothing situation i know it's not
what you want to do i get it i totally
get that but it's effectively what's
happening and
you know i don't know you know how long
you know my city has to scream
about this
i don't know how long other cities have
to scream i don't know how long
people in new hampshire have to scream
about this but to us to walk away from
this with nothing is insane
and we need to
figure out i don't know how to convey
this and i i the the chairman of uh the
chairman ruled me out of order at the
time and gave me some indulgence when i
it was it was the warning because i knew
we'd end up here and i knew we'd end up
with me
pleading with you
senator bradley so my understanding is
when
uh this bill went to the floor it was
without a committee recommendation
and
there wasn't
a clear path of what was going to happen
so it's a
pretty different scenario that we have
today
in my view
and i've also served in the house and i
know that it can be difficult to get 201
i understand the dilemma of that
but this is a different circumstance if
we're able to agree today or tomorrow
before the deadline
on a version of the bill
that targets violent crime
and we allow the people that
are on the front lines of keeping our
communities safe that opportunity to
talk to the 400 members of the house
knowing that 21 of the senators are
going to support it i think you have
very different dynamic and i think you
should give it a shot
the and you can ask the police folks
that are here
the bill that you think you can get past
you just said it in your own words
you've watered it down to the point that
it really doesn't do very much
and it also i think senator whitley's
question was pretty appropriate
um
in the hearing of
chief ho becky
[Music]
she asked if the bill is not simply
addressing those violent offenses but
also victimless crimes and i don't think
we're trying to do that but this is what
chief obecky said the language in your
bill is quite broad and that that is why
the chief supported my bill 294
as it specifically targets violent
repeat offenders this could be
problematic to the courts in terms of
those engaged in non-violent misdemeanor
level offenses being held for 36 hours
i i think you should try to give
what we know is the biggest problem a
shot and give the police chiefs
and those people that support safe homes
and safe streets
a chance to talk to your 400 members if
it fails it fails and then we have an
election this year but to say to
substitute something that really doesn't
do very much i don't know what we're
doing i do not know what we're doing in
the middle of a crime wave if we're not
representative barry um
so you know there's some confusion on
the on the chief of police side of it
because my chief of police came and
testified in for favor of 1476 and in
fact the chief of police were working
chief association was working with me
until it made it over to the senate um
so there's some confusion there i
understand they produced a letter um but
once again it comes back to the crux of
the argument of
they're not wrong we would i would love
to do the violent crime part of it
they're not wrong it's just the votes
just don't exist and we have the house
has voted on similar thing a similar
proposal from the senate and it died
three to one
to my dismay it died three to one the
senate has never voted
on 1476
as we presented it as a whole it was
changed in committee and
this 1476 came out of committee with
bipartisan support
which i believe the the similar language
in the house did not i believe it had no
recommendation it can't even get going
in the body that is supposed to be most
attuned to this issue
so
i just go back to
if we know the votes don't exist in the
house and we know there's nothing we can
do about it and we've already voted on
it two or three times something similar
one and done
what are we doing
we did not
the amendment that passed in the senate
was never voted on by the house what was
tabled was not the language in the
senate amendment that was
it's very different in that
the senate language in 294
was if you get arrested for any of those
violent offenses that were listed and
they even included another offense that
we actually
removed from the list
what that would do
is there was a presumption that you were
a danger in that there was a presumption
that you would not get
bail while being held awaiting trial and
you could overcome that but that there
was an issue people had with the
shifting of the burden
would i help but that that that that's
one and done that the house i don't like
it but they have rejected one and done
but that's not what this the senate
amendment is completely different what
that does is is no presumption that
you're not going to get bail and be held
awaiting trial all it's saying is you're
going in front of a judge not a bail
commissioner that is it if you commit if
you're charged with any of these 12
offenses
no bail commissioner judge that's it
correct it's one is it one and done
but i'm telling you what it would do no
i understand what it will do i've read
it all
is it one and done
is it a one and done system for any
crime is it a one and done system it can
be so the house the house is sh keeps
shooting this down i don't like that
they shoot it down i think if you hit
your wife you should not get br bail i i
don't know why the house can't get there
but it it can't
represent it's not this we're not
discussing pr bail does it what it has
before we
we we're gonna take a
[Music]
this is this is your place no we're good
sir
[Music]
across the street and state house
wherever it i think it's that way
yeah in the state house but don't forget
representative they didn't meet they
only met like one year out of the
biennium
you know to be honest with you i
wouldn't mind that
either but it would be a jam-packed
six months but people would have to
exercise discipline and not file 30
bills
well that that's what they told us to
sit so we're in your house we have to
we're now gonna reconvene the committee
conference on hb 307.
thank you very much uh mr chairman um
unfortunately the i think we are at an
impasse the senate cannot go along with
the house version
we could go along with including use but
only under the conditions of
defining public and private use and
unfortunately we do not have the time to
do that here
so my suggestion is that
in the upcoming session this year
that
we come back with a bill
that will define both public use and
private use
thank you very much all for your time we
really appreciate it it's always a
pleasure uh
working with criminal justice committee
and thank you very much
thank you representative burt
used to make a comment thank you mr
chairman and thank you senators um for
what you just said
uh
and from what i understand that beau
does have a carve out on some public
land that does not allow shooting so
that can happen if you want to address
that at some point
you know that was brought to my
attention today yes thank you thank you
very much uh representative and i agree
i think we can all see that this is not
an easy issue it is
fairly complex
and we just do not have time in the
committee conference in order to address
it to make sure that gun owners
their rights are respected as well as
the municipalities so i think this is
going to be an ongoing process with more
discussions in the upcoming legislative
session and hopefully we're going to be
able to resolve it next year
and lastly um it took me uh three terms
to get my snowmobile bill passed and uh
with your help this year it is going to
the governor so i think i'm glad we
could help we're glad we could help
representatives things do take time yes
it does so thank you all again very very
much for all your time and all your work
we really appreciate it and we will look
forward to hopefully working with all of
you next year if i just may make one
suggestion the issue of use i would i
would recommend putting on a separate
bill and let that
yes let that have be its own discussion
yeah i would agree things can get very
confused in the house yes i agree i
think that is a good suggestion so again
thank you all very much
this at this time we'll now reconvene
the committee conference on house bill
and when i think what we're going to
have to do is we're gonna recess until
is there uh
i hope everyone's available
sure
maybe a representative you'll find
all the voters in my district i think i
speak for the chief here and most the
chiefs they want us to address fallen
criminals and target them
and they would like this past
do we have the wrong house members maybe
we need a different body next fall if
they're willing not to support this
the senate version you can't even get
the conversation out of the committee
never mind for a discussion on the house
floor and then that's how bad then we
have the wrong committee well
i did i no one will tell you that i
didn't work my heart i i'm not saying
anything okay so i
i get the horse the stream
that's that's what i'm good at okay just
getting get into the drink we'll see you
you